c'est un régime qui est basé
essentiellement sur les fruits les
principalement au début on mange des
fruits d'accord je réparais très bien ça
paraît très naturelle mais je dirais
quelques mots sur les fruits et le fait
de consommer beaucoup de fruits alors
justement la première phase consiste à
ne manger que des fruits pendant sept à
dix jours à volonté de préférence des
fruits dit brûle graisse comme la nana
le melon la pomme la pastèque ou encore
le pamplemousse mais attendre environ
deux heures entre la consommation de
chaque fruit afin que chacun d'eux soit
bien assimilé par l'organisme ça c'est
la base c'est la phase 1 alors le
problème de cette phase 1 déjà c'est que
je vous rappelle que le grand
organisateur celui qui est votre général
dans votre corps c'est votre foi et que
le foie il n'aime pas beaucoup le
fructose haye est l'ingrédient principal
des foules comme ça qu'ils n'aiment pas
les jus même pas leur cause donc le
front des taux ce pourquoi parce que
quand vous mangez un fruit dans le fruit
vous avez un sucre qui s'appelle le
fructose sur funtouch vous ne pouvez pas
l'utiliser directement dans vos muscles
par votre coeur ou par vos cellules il
faut le transformer et qui le transforme
fois deux fois et quand il fait ça ça
lui demande beaucoup de travail ça lui
demande autant de travail que la queue
que l'alcool donc quand il fait ça il
fait pas autre chose donc quand vous
chargez en fruits donc toute la réalité
de ce régime c'est que si vous avez
entre vous avez moins de 30 ans -
trente-cinq ans que vous êtes en bonne
forme physique bonne forme qui est en
fait ce régime vous êtes une chaudière
savant 30 ans
regardez daniel
37 à 30 ans et une chaudière vous savez
bien que quand on a des ados à la maison
vous remplissez tous égaux les cas le
frigo une idée mais pourtant il reste
comme ça ils ont un métabolisme très
intense et rolo après 40 ans 50 ans
notre métabolisme diminue un peu sauf si
on a une activité physique très fort et
c'est le problème un peu de ce régime
parce que dans ce régime parce qu'au
fond de lui dire tous les régimes
peuvent marcher je vous coup la bouche
vous arrêtez de manger vous allez perdre
du poids je suis un emblème sais que
vous allez perdre du muscle c'est ça et
si vous perdez le seul endroit où on
brûle des calories je suis devant thor
mois seront débattues en fait le régime
que vous voulez mais ce qu'il faut dans
un régime et c'est là où le bât blesse
un pauvre le hollywood c'est qu'il n'y a
pas assez de protéines parce que les
protéines c'est la première chose que
mange votre votre organisme quand vous
lui elle partait pas il mange ses
muscles si vous enchaînez muscles vous
baissez ce qu'on appelle le métabolisme
de base alors on peut faire la mode ce
qu'on appelle l'empreinte carbone vous
avez une empreinte carbone soit
empreinte carbone c'est votre quantité
de qu'on l'appelle de masse maigre x 30
et on sait combien vous brûlez à l'arrêt
sans bouger à l'arrêt tu peux redire
donc donc c'est très important dans un
régime premièrement d'avoir des
protéines pour éviter de manger ses
muscles ce que c'est la première chose
que fait un organisme c'est pour ça
qu'on vous voyez des gens qui sont
emprisonnés par exemple dans de
mauvaises conditions ils ont l'air
décharné sécheresse que fergani sme il
mange d'abord les muscles parce que
c'est accessible via du sens pas prêt il
mange le gras alors la semaine de la
semaine de forêt introduire d'autres
aliments d'abord les féculents légumes
de pain une à deux fois par semaine
chaque type d'aliment doit être consommé
de sol oui mais les fruits restent
l'alimentation principale ce régime
hollywood c'est d'abord des fruits voilà
donc ses fruits dès du vor frue qui vend
deuxièmement s'est dissocié disent aussi
et c'est le les régimes qu'on a bien
connu à keynes et où l'on mange pas
avoir exactement être king même y avais
tu veux comment s'appelait ce régime il
était complètement dit c'était demis
roussos les micros sont survenus demis
roussos un jour quand je paie un
chevalier doc revoir d'écrire sur les
sur la tête
et donc c'est un régime aussi dissocier
c'est à dire quand vous commencez à
manger des fruits il faut d'abord faut
pas mélanger les fruits entre eux
adacore attendre deux heures entre
chaque fruit quoi ça d'abord je mange
une pomme oui après je me prends un
petit anna après un si long ça prend un
portable on voit là et après une
pastèque faut du temps quand même rires
je mange tous les toutes les toutes les
deux heures je mange un fruit date après
8 heures si vous avez décidément j'ai
appris parce qu'après ce voyage est
envoyé chez sa mère
c'est pourquoi est-ce si long dans les
autres semaines vous pouvez réintroduire
les protéines mais les protéines sans
les glucides et les glucides oui docteur
pardonnez-moi mais la première semaine
si on mange que des fruits ça fait pas
aller on n'a pas trop mal au ventre est
allé tout à fait parce que en alphabet
du frigo
est vide et vitamines et en fait ces
fibres un moment ça peut être très
irritant pour les gens qu'on allait
geler pendant une semaine à valence 10
mois avec les finales à dire a dit
d'abord il faut des régimes il est très
difficile de dire à tout le monde mais
si vous faites ça vous aurez ca sur
chaque être ici est différent parce que
tu mange des fruits du changement
[Rires]
alors [ __ ] effectivement un régime
uniquement fructidor d'accord c'est pas
très bon 10 pour les bras la retraite
c'est vrai et voilà oui est ce que le
nutella c'est considéré comme un fruit
le nutella n'est pas été
question on peut manger des fruits à
volonté c'est à dire qu'on peut manger
deux kilos de fruits parle de kilos de
pommes on perd quand même du poids ah
non non non
en fait c'est assez limité c'est ainsi
pokal oricom régime 5 en gros c'est un
régime qui s'appelait d'abord avant ça
s'appelait de beverly hills dice arias
il ya 15 ans ou 20 ans et
bravo et en fait il a été il a été remis
au goût du jour mais effectivement si
vous avez 20 30 ans vous êtes en pleine
forme une vraie chaudière car que je dis
je dire parce que ce qu'on pense à
daniel
chaudière enfin parce qu'il faut
comprendre un problème instinct trucks
très simple un organisme c'est comme une
machine si vous faites rentrer plus de
charbon dans la chaudière que vous
n'utilisez pas votre locomotive elle va
finir par exploser c'est un peu la même
principe 25 oui bien sûr mais du coup
c'est fait se mettent alors je suis pas
une chaudière mais le matin par exemple
du coup c'est du vrai ses muscles et
vous êtes gentil merci être musclé ses
études jodie tu veux te mettre la
merci des noms c'est pour vous dire du
coup c'est une fausse idée le matin moi
je me saoule à férin un jus de
pamplemousse près c'est juju d'orange
pressé tout ça en fait très mauvais pour
mon choix alors alors ça répond de votre
âge dans ça dépend de votre à son nom
brûlé mais une chose est certaine ouais
je voulais dit quand le x voir arriver
du fructose ça lui demande beaucoup de
travail en avoir été genre émiratie le
matin alors vous avez 20 ans dhr vous
avez une vie un machin partenaires à 20
ans vous savez très bien vous pouvez
vous dormir à 3 heures du matin vous
lever à 7h et vous êtes en forme j'en ai
fait la cancha namy qu'après ce que
c'est qu'est ce que lui maintenant si
vous prenez un jugement avait beaucoup
de fric tu aurais demande ça veut dire
que vous allez prendre une charge de
fructose ou pour votre foi très
importante et pendant qu'il fait ça il
fait pas la même chose d'accord voilà la
crise je pense que c'est un régime qui
serait pas mal pour benjamin parce qu'en
fait le régime disent au salon n'en
réussit et six chiens ont vu
c'est que justement de faire un régime
dissocié qui est basée sur les enzymes
différentes et qui ont su neutralisent
pas ça évite la fermentation et donc les
phares violence ça évite de lui voilà
donc oui ça va les fruits services de
péter
les fameuses flatulences chara a fait
parlons-en
les pâtes les allées contraignez sur ce
sujet sujet à caution en fait les
flatulences qu'est ce que c'est c'est
effectivement de la fermentation et on a
on a beaucoup dit que l'on commençait
déjà à fermenter dans le dans l'intestin
faits remontant à des fous du temps
quand même hein c'est commence avec pour
lever par exemple une baguette avec une
de la levure de la levure pour de pain
ça va prendre entre 2h et 3h donc pour
fermenté et faire faire de fermenter de
2,2 des fruits dans l'estomac ça va
prendre beaucoup plus de temps par
contre dans les fruits à des fibres
insolubles les fibres insolubles par
définition elles sont pas avalé sont pas
digérées elles vont dans le col on
savait qu'un estomac après il ya
l'intestin grêle 6 à 8 mètres et après
l'alcool on sait le grand fermenteurs le
colon quoi au nord parce que le grelle
l'estomac il broie broie tout sur une
espèce de 2 bien sûr fait ce qu'il
fallait le pilote qui s'ouvre de temps
en temps pour pas que tout passe corps
et de la diarrhée ça passe de temps en
temps ça passe dans graine kif
qu'absorbe les glucides les protides les
vitamines et ainsi de suite et après
tout ce qui reste du prochain bol
fécales non le côlon qui est le grand
fermenteurs et luis fernandez si vous
avez trop de fibres insolubles bravo si
on avait trop de fibres de structure à
ce moment là il va fermenter faire les
bactéries vont tout faire et quand elles
ferment tel fonds actifs à ce terminal a
été ce gars a dit il va finir 5 avec une
substance qui s'appelle le stère mobily
nos gènes ça me permet d'avoir une
mauvaise odeur qui nous évite de re
consommer ah ouais là mais non à ce
moment là ça va faire un peu assez à
saint pourçain alors égal mais à voir ci
dessus non
le gaz de ville ne sent rien on a mis du
mercaptan dedans pour savoir qu'à une
fuite chinois sans rien d'accord dont un
impresionnant l'être humain ont été
tentées de remanger ce cas ça a bien sûr
donc
combiner à sarko bil in pas et donc
cesser a ajouté parce que la nature
s'est aperçu que si on fait ça ces
comportements là étaient des
comportements qui était extrêmement
mauvais pour notre marie mas i mas sinon
si tu dis tu smirnov c'est vous qui
m'avez s'appelle le truck series bil in
munster cofinimmo notait zostères qu'obi
wan billy billy billy qui nous permet
d'en manger sur quelque mal à manger web
interview vous avez dit à mathieu que
c'était une chaudière et oui c'était
d'ailleurs un compliment dans votre
bouche c'est ce que cyril admettent une
chaudière cyril hanouna je ne connais
pas sa masse musculaire et ténor robert
beynat importante monstre sous ses
dehors comme ça allait je l'avais touché
tous ces faits
je pense qu il fait de l'exercice je
montrais silva fait de la musculation
voilà pour une seule raison c'est que
pour faire ce qui fait on peut avoir un
bon gars vous il ya un cul de
reginald
tous les tons
je suis ça je veux dire le gêner le jeu
mais le vrai conseil
a joué quatre jours de sport voilà le
vrai conseil chaque monstre c'est de
faire de l'exercice on sait aujourd'hui
sur des centaines de millions de gens si
vous voulez être monstrueux comme l'uic
où il faut pratiquer trois fois
cinquante minutes d'exercice physique
anar par semaine et il faut se
mouiller la chemise c'est pourquoi
est-ce qu'il faut mouiller la chemise
après vous embête plus avec le foie
c'est pour ça que je les crée dans mon
livre c'est qu'en fait le foie
qu'envoûtant parle comme ça il ya un
litre et demi de sang qui passe par
minute à un litre et demi c'est beaucoup
mais ça reste beaucoup et pendant 7
minutes il fait des centaines de
réactions chimiques pour vous détoxifier
pour faire le métabolisme si vous faites
de l'exercice en mouillant la chemise
c'est à dire que vous faites vous faites
ça brouille gens vous augmenter le débit
cardiaque gros des toxines et bien vous
le débit cardiaque 6 x 2 ah oui vous
multiplier par deux la détoxification ah
ouais c'est à dire que le foie à une
détoxification je m'excuse du mot cette
idée me dépendantes débit n'est pas moi
c'est pas du tout la transpiration
et votre choix qui fait quoi d'accord
votre foi qu'il fait ce qui régule la
glycémie le pancréas fait d'insuline
mais c'est le foie qui réguler la
glycémie c'est le foie qui transforme le
fructose glucose c'est le foie qui capte
les vitamines c'est le choix qu'il fait
à la bile pour digérer je sais le foie
qui sait la coagulation portant sur 1
fois
d'ailleurs la nature ou le créateur a
fait un truc génial il a multiplié sa
taille par trois ouais c'est à dire que
vous avez un fois largement
surdimensionnée pour vos besoins ah
ouais d'accord donc vous pouvez compter
sur lui mais soyez gentils avec grâce et
sa façon de charger pas quoi donc mais
c'est bien de là encore pour le foie
demande pas d'avoir ses il faut pas
d'alcool je suis une bête
tu ne pas tricher vous mangez des fruits
je mange des fruits bien sûr vachement
je vais vous pétez du coup mais
des fous d'animateur
de fait pâtissent de
ces rencontres
huit fois
voilà jean d'alos toujours très
intéressés sur steam et dangereux ouais
exactement bon faire il est dangereux si
vous avez 50 ans il avait une vie peut
être un peu compliqué que vous êtes
stressé dernière ne le fait pas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]